peace be with you welcome to the D
Sharmini your host ascribe if you
haven't already guess what we're going
to be talking about
they put Jane before Mary Mary Jane
whatever it's called marijuana cannabis
we're gonna be straight with you today
we're going to be keepin it real I'm
going to be talking about this topic
it's become something very casual and
many Muslims are get involved in it
having some misinterpretations about it
so we're gonna set the record straight
we're gonna have a very frank discussion
here with my next guest on the D show
you're gonna be very enlightened don't
go anywhere sit through the whole show
so you can make up your mind the next
time you're thinking about lighting up
here on the D show my next guest don't
go anywhere be right back
[Music]
as-salaam alaikum peace be with you oh I
think mr. Lam but I'm not a lot of water
cattle how are you doing my friend
wonderful yourself good I'm doing
something laughs we got a very exciting
topic to talk about talk about you know
people sit back nowadays and it's become
very casual you know to smoke marijuana
people equate it was something natural
it's a natural plant and what not and
what what hit home for me really was
something that was more personal because
a brother had brought to our attention
that some young brother was inquiring
not more inquiring he was trying to
persuade because he had shared his
facebook page with one brother and the
brother had noticed that there was a
picture promoting actually marijuana so
brother let's say brother X is talking
about brother wine he's like he asked
him he said look brother I'm kind of
confused you know I thought you had get
this you our houses of Quran you
memorized the Quran and I really had
deep profound respect for you know but
now I'm seeing you promoting you know
this plant you know it says on there you
know share a plant people are seeing his
picture right now it says share a plant
with your friends
he was like once he was in shock and
then he had texted one of his friends
and he said what do you say to someone
who says half the scholars say that
smoking marijuana half half Wow half
says halau half say is Haram so the
brother said I tell him he's crazy
Shaitaan is pimping him what would you
say you know Subhan Allah I don't know
know half our other half you know any
sane person who knows and you know about
drugs and intoxicants and so on they
know they're also allies of Allah do
sell them he clearly stated that
anything that intoxicates you
it's prohibited and then and then as the
scholar said they measure that
accordingly
you know maybe cigarettes maybe
marijuana and it's lights were not
existent back in the profits they
specifically with these names
that's colors our time along with the
doctors because he can't do one group
without the other you have the doctors
and you have the scholars of the Dean
they do their work research they need
put on the table
and I approve see I'm not aware of any
scholar then those are such intoxicants
and drugs and end up saying yeah you
know what sure go for it
I'm sick a lot of drugs future and false
understanding even if they say well
there are some benefits and yes you
might find a benefit or two but what's
the harm behind them thousands hundreds
Allah knows best and then they change
the terms of it right they say things
that you know sooth is the mind seeing
that grants you happiness and they
change the terms so the baseline is that
it intoxicates you as the province of
asylum said as well whatever intoxicates
you in large quantities is also Haram in
small quantities so it doesn't matter
took a bucket again like to get your
grandma said that as soon as I get you
in tight covers the the UH coda my
exactly clouds it wonderful then that's
you know bidding you know it's a panel I
in even things like that you know
scholars are required to support us and
so on but sometimes even you yourself
the process of al-ahly Western Amina
said sin has two signs for it that which
your heart does not feel comfortable
towards or your doubtful and number two
something they don't like people to see
you doing so I ask everyone who consumes
that I asked them by Allah if they know
a pilot is smoking weed would they go
and write in that airplane I asked them
by Allah to be genuine to be sincere if
the one who's been doing an operation on
their parents has talked and has taken a
joint Allah a drug here and there just
this marijuana are they gonna allow that
doctor to complete the operation on
their parents I asked them by Allah I'm
not I can no shake no scholar I'm [ __ ]
to that person what would they say see
if you feel uncomfortable maybe that's
the alarm in the heart that Allah has
blessed you with the sutra let me know
consciousness if you should say or that
innate nature there's something you need
to keep in mind so from the technical
from the from the perspective now is
this allowed this is pretty much clear
that you know there's a consensus of
scholarship that have agreed that this
is something that is prohibited that
anything that intoxicates use in the
Quran is in the Sunnah this is something
there is no and beauty and
Beauty it's not ambiguous you noticed
one of my teachers on our ulema he said
the fatwa the ruling of cigarettes
imagine cigarettes imagine you thought
marijuana and go to the next level the
rulings on the box
what is this what does it say on the box
a cigarette pack this thing may cause
you lung cancer it's done were you
arguing for you shiftless uneven
taymiyah he says actually according to
him he said there's an itchy matter the
consensus amongst the scholars then he
specifies hashish which is weed it is
prohibited to done our negotiable I want
to back it up because there's a
difference between let's say because in
this case you have someone who you know
had memorized the Quran now there's a
difference between someone memorizing
Quran understanding the Quran and took
what that's involved because Polly want
a cracker
okay you know the parrot you can you can
train her to memorize some crowd or yes
what what of what points the point is it
and when when further the brother was
talking to the brother this other
brother who was promoting the weed who I
was at one point was seeming like he was
really strong in the D so I put it to
the public he appears very practice yeah
he had mentioned that I'm not really
what you think I am you know I'm not
that knowledgeable you follow me okay so
when we look back I mean how important
is it when we really start teaching our
kids we start learning the Quran that we
learn it with understanding absolutely
no learning with understanding is
something that you will seek till the
last breath that you have and then when
I assure of the law and the whys of the
process tell them when they asked about
the character of the Prophet they said
he is a walking what Quran so he applied
the one there's some narrations that the
Companions they said we never moved on
to memorizing the next verse until we
memorize and applied the first verse
subhanAllah so that's something
definitely it's very critical and
applying this ayat is a lifelong journey
and may Allah allow us to apply what we
learn and that's what we say may Allah
make it an excuse for us to enter Jannah
and not an excuse against us we know the
level you know there's quite a big
difference between someone who is an
someone who is a scholar someone that's
really a fad whose memory whose who's
living this Dean there's much respect we
have to respect our teacher I had a
conversation with someone who I thought
was actually Muslim but then at the end
talking to him I was trying to give him
some advice and at the end he said look
I'm not really religious and he started
talk to me about Darwinism he started
saying you know I don't want to I'm not
involved in all these mullahs and all
those you know religious people they're
the most corrupt and I really caught me
off guard then I said you know what
you're absolutely right you know that
the Hellfire is gonna be started with
scholars so far law is gonna start
that's true so I want to talk about this
there could be some some shake some
person even smoking he can be a Mufti
smokiness double Booker is he our
example at the end of the day may Allah
protect us from being under such people
you know this is why the scholars are
very high in a high position Allah said
Shahid Allahu Allah says Allah the first
one who believes testifies there's no
Lord but Allah art is Allah he's a shade
Allah Allah Allah Allah and Allah talks
about the Angels he talks about the
scholars so Allah you know appreciates a
scholar so scholars is in a very
sensitive position so that's why and
people follow us colors saying a very
odd opinion and may Allah protect us and
this is a fitna from you know that can
follow up on people but what I'd say is
that just you know use your logic as
well as scholar tells you something I'm
not saying you have to be a scholar but
at least have some common sense if you
have a thousand scholars that tell you
this is prohibited non-negotiable
this is sin that then you use this one
odds you know you call scholar Allah
eylem and see what's his reasoning and
be very just with the ass for the
reasoning respectfully Sheikh with all
respect you know I know your island but
with respect to what's your reasoning
behind saying it's Highland how is it
possible and see why it tells you know
otherwise that ways are not Haram and so
on when you have this evidence we're
gonna take a break and we wipe out more
here in the Dean show to talk about
marijuana
mary-jane cannabis what other names they
got for it they call it pickles onions
and mushrooms we'll be right back
don't go anywhere please subscribe to
the DCO follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below
continuing on talking about marijuana
something that's really amongst the
youth even adults it becomes something
real casual but you know what trumps
everything at the end of the day is if
we've connected our heart to the maker
of the heart our creator this is it this
is where we get our guidance from now I
really you know when I'm thinking about
this can we um can you imagine and you
take off from here if the sahaba
hmm our beloved the last autonomous
imprint sentiment I'm sending it from
Hamas awesome getting stoned getting
high saying I got to think clear you
know because you see people come up with
all these you know a different reasoning
you know I can think clearer I'm more
focused I'm one not even though you know
they did study CNN people see right now
we'll go to a clip Rick as a consultant
prepared our marijuana smoking lab three
volunteers each took a practice run on a
course set up by the Thurston County
Sheriff's Office stop until she wiped
out a cone which would have been
indicative of backing into a pole or
maybe a citizen on the on a sidewalk the
sheriff's officer driving instructor and
even Addie agreed she would not be safe
if she was on a public road she would be
a danger yeah yeah definitely that's
dangerous to confirm the volunteers were
driving impaired we treated them like
anyone else pulled over and suspected of
drug use the county's drug recognition
expert put them through a 12-step
evaluation checking things like their
balance heart rate and blood pressure
were also checked they all had issues
including Jeff who couldn't find his
nose with his finger tip I would say
that all three would have been arrested
for driving under the influence where
you know what the expert have said like
you actually operating machinery a car
you if that's legal and endanger
yourself in danger however experts warn
that weed could negatively affect brain
development in teens and cause
short-term memory dysfunction coughing
and respiratory disorders it also
impairs the people's ability to drive
but what about from this perspective
here's someone who's that who's you know
want to be respected you're a scholar
you know you somebody who's committed to
the day how could someone take you
seriously if you're someone who just
gets stolen and gets awesome yeah
absolutely especially taking someone
seriously as they were mentioned about
the pilot the doctrine so and this is
very serious you know from from a
medical field in the simple term you
know whenever we eat something sit in a
gathering that we enjoy there's a
dopamine level that is released in a
very natural level Allah made us like
that you know in the cooler shaken
jalapeno bit but that Allah has made
everything you know you know settle
Allah has calculated everything when you
take these in toxicants marijuana and
it's likes it it really releases more
dopamine than what than that which is
natural so your excitement level is
above which is average and normal and
people get excited okay they love it and
when you experience this you're no
longer satisfied with whatever Allah
made normal so every time the Golem or I
need that excitement I need this isn't
that so you go for something that's
unnatural so then you stick to it
because you're more dopamine and all
that stuff etc so when someone is at
that level as you said how you can take
them serious and then when they walk
like that they smell bad and so on so
how is that it's a whole set of things
you know if the prophet of allah i said
them advised us not to go to the massage
it the mosques when we eat onion and I
know things out disturbing imagine if
you're walking with smoking a cigarette
smoking weed how disturbing to the smell
so I'm not just talking about even
health-wise even disturb is to other
people it just this is a package of
things that I truly believe every
genuine man and woman who consumes that
I believe so has an atom weight of a man
or belief or any sanity left they would
know that it has some serious effects
this will definitely I mean okay with
the red eye dry mouth munchies what nod
your you sleep a lot you can sleep a lot
in house this is gonna definitely affect
you your Avada after you worship your
you know your life is you know the
question lies in that - why are you
consuming such stuff is that why most
people they'll tell you according to
what we read here and there most of them
feel stress I'm stressed out I
personally know someone I saw them
taking some in toxicants I asked why
because my father and mother
continuously fight and my father is
actually physically abusive to my mother
so their solution to that you know
depression they're going through is
smoking cigarettes and intoxicants now I
feel bad for you me a lot lift every
hardship from our brothers and sisters
really but is that really the stress
relief method you know the prophesy said
I'm told us you know one time a man was
putting some alcohol together
humph so rasoolallah you know stock
intends authentic hadith so the man said
the oil this is cure this alcohols are
cured to me the promise says lies at the
legs a bit ah WA this is not here and no
that read this is disease law or you
know don't think that Allah will put
something there a cure in something
there's Hara obviously you might have
some moments where the doctors a few
don't mind any just touch on this you
know you so using intoxicants as means
of here and other scholars have
mentioned few points for you to use an
intoxicant which is naturally Haram as
mentioned is acceptable in three
conditions that some scholars I've
mentioned number one is the doctor
doctor a Muslim doctor needs to
prescribe it for you like you know easy
to take this marijuana you take this and
not tarry when whatever it may be it's
not a Muslim doctor than a doctor who's
trustworthy non-muslims fine but knows
about your stomach values and number two
this has to be the only drug or only
medication available there's no
substitution whatsoever and number three
it has to be within the quantity that is
needed for your cure and so on so those
people have to keep that in mind and not
exaggerate you'll see arguments for this
I mean you'll see people who will just
go out of their way
you know argue something do you see that
when you really want to follow your
desires yes you will do everything in
the end everything to try to justify
that yes you know as Allah says tejada
allahu how some people take their Lord
as their desires they will do the work
the government did go to this it will do
that to legalize it you'll do whatever
it takes do you know day and night
working on subhanAllah I mean a lot may
Allah protect us and make our desires or
a lot lee is pleased with I mean there's
something you need to keep in mind you
know I just want a very foundational
role you know some people say oh
marijuana means this means that it's not
really the end toxic
can let them call it whatever name they
want the bottom rule is what Allah said
and whether you see the benefits he
don't that's not you know leave it up to
allah rasool is a said at one time he
grabbed gold and he grabbed silver and
this is another example of how we submit
to Allah's rulings gold and silk sari he
told the people this is prohibited on
the mend permissible on the women
I personally I'm not sure about your
audience do they know why gold is Haram
on men
why silk Allah knows best but what I
know is I submit in toxicants are haram
i submit to allah spare time solo
suicide let you know i'm hoping a lot
except from that we're gonna take a
break we'll come back this very
interesting topic here in the d show
please subscribe to the diva follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below so
basically at the end of the day someone
who is chosen constantly to submit to
the Creator to obey the crater loves the
Creator wants to follow the example the
last one of mr. program Humvees he's got
no she's got no business getting stoned
using dope
just you know it's not when you use
these things you know it's it when you
use it you say these getting high
correct you got no business stolen to
them you know you got no business
Antonis things I mean there's something
with the heart now we have to go there's
a bigger this is a symptom of something
greater absolutely so Paula first of all
we ask allah subhanaw taala to lift the
hardships or brothers and sisters once
again really because sometimes you go
through these avenues maybe a lack of
knowledge
you know overzealousness and you name it
and most of the time is peer pressure by
the way yeah so peer pressure is very
serious I actually read a statement that
says that most people are addicted to
drugs is due to peer pressure in terms
of someone says a lot you try this out
and so on so may Allah protect us and
grant you all righteous companionship I
mean our Anatomy when when someone you
know goes to these things to just you
know stress relief and so on but still
aligns to the law do seldom wanted a man
it came to him and he told them all so
Allah how much they say some Elano said
like ask allah to set his peace and
blessings upon you can i do it like two
thirds of the time one-third of the time
he kept mentioning so the Prophet says
the more you say it the better then the
prophet a sunset in certain quantity you
see so many times then it releases any
pressure for me like a big sea it takes
over here and I should have never faced
that sorry it relieves you from pressure
and anxiety and stress and Allah
forgives your sins so there's a lot of
options in which people can feel
comfortable about themselves in terms of
you know there's a lot of stress
depression and pressure Allah Allah also
last time has given you avenues to
relieve yourself so he asked about to
allow us to follow the Sunnah floral
lines to the Larios and there's a lot
well soon like I said for example he
said whoever says has to be allahu la
ilaha illa huwa ala if they were called
to horrible our show them seven times in
the morning and evening what happens you
say that then Allah Japan with Dada will
suffice you suffice of everything
suffice me of what everything your
hardships your difficulties and so on so
may Los Angeles allow us to be patient
and trust him without you know with
whatever struggle that we think you kind
of only the Creator knows the future but
you go through experiences in life yeah
and you gain certain wisdoms Allah gives
you wisdom to foresee things if you
obviously you try to walk across the
expressway not looking you're gonna most
likely hit by a car alright so you see
certain doors opening up you see where
the Creator is honoring certain people
let's say we go back to someone
memorizing it's such a noble thing you
know someone memorizes the book of the
crater you know the the Quran and you
see what's this statement from Oman or
the Aloha know where he said that we
were people that Allah gave us is I gave
us under 103 slam and you see someone
being honored and people hold you to
such a high level you know and that's a
responsibility also certainly but then
you go away from that and you see a door
of humiliation what's the rest of the
statement where he said that now whoever
goes and seeks it to anything out
through the dunya and any of these
things any evany beside Islam
humiliations that's it regardless this
is scary thing isn't it absolutely
what are your what are your a know
Subhan Allah you know if he everyone on
it a dignity if you ever want to be
respected
just only through believing the
osmanthus cuz Allah named himself
you know unless the most vulnerable and
Allah clearly tells us on the problem
Allah if you seek honor and respect
through any other Avenue it's not just
you will not achieve it you'll be
humiliated somehow lost may Allah
protect us really you know for example
just something that came to mind there's
one brother who in a noble position name
is Muhammad and so on and he went for a
job interview and then the interviewer
asked him so your name is Muhammad is
like no call me mo now let's double
hanaman holla that's besides the topic
then he at the end of the interview the
manager told them so as a Muslim I think
you need to take an hour off on Fridays
right he's like no no no I'm good
it's according mean is it no no I'm good
I can pray all five prayers when I get
home I'm a very dedicated person to work
is it but your colleagues take a take an
hour off like a Muslim colleagues it's
yeah I'm very dedicated to my job doing
about it
interviews done two weeks pass he was
waiting for a phone call you know no
phone call so he calls him the cool oh I
made an interview my name is Mohammad
missus and that you remember me yes I
remember you I was here I think I
qualified for everything he asked for
everything checkmark then he asked the
guy why didn't get hired he said you
know we looked into a better candidate
but I want to know why like what is it I
lacked he's like you want the honest
truth I want the honest truth he said
you were not dedicated enough to your
own religion how can I expect you be
dedicated to the job Wow it's upon Allah
and they saw honor through the job
position and so on but humilation fell
upon them
hey man let me I'm gonna protect us here
I mean that's another sign you'll see
someone going in this direction and next
thing you know you have to hang around
certain friends also probably like the
same thing so now you also probably hang
around people you shouldn't be hanging
around with I'm still right you start
losing good friends
or you used to even start promoting this
stuff Subhan Allah all right and you're
earning more bad deeds yeah and then
probably creating a rift in your family
which Islam came to preserve the family
you're probably just obeying your
parents no causing them grief so a whole
world of corruption starts to open up
why because you need to get stoned
Subhan Allah you need to escape the
reality maybe of your shortcomings the
reality of hardships and how to overcome
them so many people that take drugs you
know we
escaping something that they maybe don't
have faced most of them many of them
like for example and Justin Bieber and
their likes well just maybe you're a
good-looking man you got all the girls
you got all the money you're still young
you're strong so realistically speaking
generally you want to be as cautious or
as awake as possible but would you
resort to drugs because the thing that
is looking for contentment and the you
know tranquility and peace and mind is
never there so why not be as absence
because I tried everything it never
worked out so you know what I don't have
to try anymore I want to be as absent
and as conscious as possible you take
drugs you lose your mind in a certain
extent right your focus can you sleep a
lot do you minimize your exposure to in
this life so may Allah allow me and
allow you to all our listeners to have
our hearts steadfast upon with upon the
truth and upon the path of Rasul Allah
in somebody else I'm really you connect
a lot with the young they really enjoy
listening to you what would you say to a
young brother out there who is able to
listen now and maybe he's or she's gone
down this direction what advice would
you give first of all I tell them
hamdulillah that you're still alive and
listening to this advice you know
listening to this show on program so
this means the evening la whenever you
see a sign that Allah has given you you
have to utilize it you know you just you
know point on YouTube this isn't that
download talked about drugs or what is
that about you you have to utilize these
signs Allah showing you some love Allah
what do they all loving so you realize
that number two if you're falling into
it my advice is that don't give up on
leaving it the evening less doable and
you have to do your absolute best to
struggle and my best advice to those who
consume drugs in any way shape or form
that my best advice to them I can think
of right now is to change your
companionship move away you know the guy
who killed nine people he heard that I
did before I killed nine nine people
when he killed the hundred he went to
the scholar afterwards he tell him I
kill a hundred people what should I do
the scholar genius he didn't say you
know stay in the message read Quran
that's wonderful no that's wonderful but
he went beyond he said you know what you
are living around an area of corrupted
people the scholar told them leave that
Arian go to another area
mr. random unknown go to that other area
that has good people so I advise you to
to release from good companionship and
no as a loss of cinnamon or three useful
in the matter so you sort of every every
hardship there are two eases that come
and much more
so know that other relief is coming soon
but you have to cope your self with some
knowledge and I advise them to post seek
some knowledge of how to cope with
hardships if Allah is merciful than why
do the tragedies happen listen get to
educate yourself more and more know how
short life is know that consequences
from a medical field how harmful this is
to you to your body even to your manhood
without going into much details that
people can do their own research so just
look at it be genuine be sincere and
continuously ask Allah for assistance
continuously ask Allah for assistance
because you will never change I will
never die as a Muslim you will not die
as a Muslim unless Allah assist us with
that so we ask what to make it easy on
all of us and allow us to have our last
word in this life letti like la la
my mother also beautiful thank you so
much I mean my pleasure wonderful advice
it's like a look I appreciate your time
thank you so much Mike wasn't cut all
right that was really a great topic I
hope you got to benefit and we want to
bring you more of the subscribe right
now if you haven't subscribed and we got
to clear up the confusion if you were
misled to believe we all make mistakes
but now when the truth come comes to us
we can rectify those mistakes and it's
not 50 50 where 50 percent say it's
allowed another 50% of scholars say it's
not no no no this is very clear anything
that intoxicates the mind the fogs
divine alters the mind is prohibited in
this Deen in this way of life that
you've chosen to live now you can either
follow your desires or the truth comes
to you and you submit and it doesn't
matter if it's the biggest Mufti in the
world with the biggest beard telling you
it's allowed at the end of the day what
do we say that the Hellfire look we have
to respect the scholars are the
inheritors of the prophets because they
have the in the knowledge but at the
same time you have many doing opposite
to what they're supposed to be doing it
can be a ton of information
on the donkey's back but if that person
doesn't have taqwa consciousness of the
creator and is not living and guiding
people to that which is correct then the
creator talks about starting the
Hellfire with scholars such as that and
it's a very scary thing we have a great
responsibility here to help guide the
people to that what is right and it's
wrong to go ahead and advocate that
someone can go ahead and smoke dope and
get high because you have no business
doing that in this Deen so I hope this
was made very clear and why do you want
to get high that's you know the real
this that's a symptom of a greater
problem
why do you want to get stoned can you
imagine going to the Messenger of Allah
and asking him o rasûlullah can I go
ahead would you allow me to smoke some
dope to get high what would he say to
you be sincere with yourself and if this
doesn't again help facilitate for you to
leave this stuff alone along with you
really sincerely within yourself asking
Allah asking the Creator asking him look
to facilitate ease in this because this
is something that's easy to get addicted
to and then you find yourself doing
things that you wouldn't normally do
when you weren't intoxicated when your
judgment wasn't clouded you even go to a
level that you probably steal you start
you getting you get around the the worst
of friends you're making disharmony in
your family Allah I'm honored you now
you are Hafiz of Quran and what happens
now
you see that starts getting taken away
that dignity that honour you start
losing it you start posting things on
your on your Facebook page advocating
for this you become a helper of the
Shaitaan
well he's pimped you and now he's had
recruited you to go ahead and pin others
for what something that's clear you can
invite them to that's good you inviting
them to go ahead and share the dope the
ganja you out of your mind of
course when you smoke in the junk so
it's out of the love that we do these
programs to really help facilitate
goodness and I hope that the heart is
open and the mind definitely needs to be
like a parachute to function properly
and if the mind is open the heart is
open this topic is case closed
it's shut if you really want to do what
the Creator wants you to do and not
follow your desires anything that blocks
you from your purpose from that
connection with definitely how many
times have you probably overslept um you
miss a lot we don't only have time to
get it to all of the fitnah that's
opened up from you doing this stuff and
that's gonna continue to open up and the
lost you're gonna be in because there's
only one way one direction that you're
headed and that's towards being a loser
you're a winner and stick to the winning
path get off this drugs brother you got
no business getting high and I hope this
has been a benefit subscribe if you
haven't hit it right now peace be with
you
with love Islamic please subscribe to
the deanship follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below